[Applause]
I have no agenda here to tell you this
but I never met you until just a few
moments ago yeah but you come across on
television is exactly as you are as full
of joy and you will have a career as
long as you want one in this you can't
you can't look at your personality and
not be joyful yeah it's happening you
don't get depressed looking at you with
me people oh the other room they know
you they start chanting until you can't
[Laughter]
wait you also made a movie and so did
you fancy booze and mine mine mine is
contractual obligated was horrible what
was my movie model it's about two hours
it was about two hours two holes is what
it was no it was ringmaster and it came
out right when my show was really doing
well and so they wanted to make a movie
about it ringmaster because I really
it's a circus my show so and that's what
we did and when I
I never made a movie before so when I
started doing the movie then I would
joke around and say well now one of the
Oscars so I got a buddy of mine to write
an acceptance speech for me you know
because I was confident but he wrote the
speech and the first thing in the speech
is I'd like to thank my wife Connie
Chung I love Morrie but I'm not Mari I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this